l'invité du 19/20 gérard schivardi
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ou m'en voudrez pas si je
vous dit vous êtes le moins connu des
candidats alors vous êtes soutenus par
le parti des travailleurs branche du
trotskisme aimez vous dites moi
j'appartiens de pas au parti des
travailleurs est bien le côté voulait
que le porte parole des maires et les
maires ne veulent pas que vous soyez
leur porte parole
qui êtes vous et pour qui voulez vous je
suis le canalise à deux mairies
socialistes
vous semblez déjà une candidate
socialiste sous le lit toujours pas moi
un livre le guide je ne vais pas
commenter un reçu je suis entouré de
berne thoune en politique
une partie des travailleurs et et
pourquoi soutenu par le parti des
travailleurs où sont mis d'accord sur
une plateforme de travail voilà je
préférais comme dieu oui on va venir
mais pas c'est juste pour essayer de
vous cernez quand même parce que ça fait
pratiquement trois candidats trotskistes
ou ne sait pas trop ce qui se tournent
le sait je suis socialiste
un point c'est tout alors ça car comme
on a parlé de la santé il ya un instant
vous c'est un peu votre cheval de
bataille ces services publics ruralité
mais alors on vous détachant
complètement de l'europe rupture totale
pourquoi et comment c'est possible
aujourd'hui pas de l'europe des traités
européens du traité de maastricht que
vous avez signé parce que j'étais parti
socialiste parce que françois mitterrand
nous avons expliqué au site la solution
égal nous avons dit nous avons
antillaise
il faut les conséquences il faut le
reconnaître ne parle plus alors pour
chats rupture non mais je n'atteindrai
s'inquiète de ce que j'ai tendu avec les
maires j'ai eu un tour nous avons pour
la réouverture tous les hôpitaux et de
toutes les maternités de proximité et
compris les vivent pas camus rurales
déjà j'aurai pour à jouer nous devons et
exigeant qu'on nous rembourse les ce1 75
milliards d'euros que l'état ce cadeau g
zone de prise et qu'il faut qu'il y ait
un trou de la sécu et social
si on veut rentrer six chaises des 15
milliards d'aud qui nous sont dues aux
ouvrir et aux patrons puisque
j'ai comme un étalon pas à sommet social
il n'y a plus de trous et on pourra
soigner convenablement
ça sent très simples comme solution
c'est koné nationalisation vous voulez
renationaliser vous voulez
renationaliser quoi les banques un ca en
entreprise toutes les entreprises déjà
qu'ils ont été mis en place avec notre
impôt le vôtre est le mien nous avons pm
peut promettre tout les effets
structurants place reçoit et des affûts
gdf sncf les chantiers dans le scénario
tout nous avons financé ces deux prises
qui est l etat avait notre bourg l'état
les a bravé somme ridicule à des fonds
privés et maintenant les fonds privés
faute des milliards alors que ces mères
de rue nous à partir appartenir on nous
parle toujours autour d'investissements
là au moment où il y aurait retrouvé
investissements pour les france y est
pour le peuple et ses alentours à des
années folles de patio un discours qu un
peu surprenant la part d'un chef
d'entreprise vous êtes vous aussi chef
d'entreprise c'est un discours qui
s'adresse au monde ouvrier à mai ouvrira
mauvais je vous considère un crumble aux
fruits comme n'importe quel oui vous
savez le retirer à montreuil toi je
voulais quand même sourit je suis même
titre que quand je vois quand même que
on a bradé le patrimoine offre ainsi
bradé a déjà un niveau des milliards de
l'argent que nous avons penu jeudi le
retour d'effort été et il voulait merlou
disons en plus il faut sortir des
marchés
il faut revenir socialiste comme vous
dites là on est déjà au tour ce que vous
parlez encore au nom des maires qui a
beaucoup beaucoup plus que ce qu'on
croit qu'ils me soutiennent actuellement
et et or de il ya de plus en plus alors
c'est ce que vous dites bombes les
sondages on sait qu'ils n'ont que valeur
spontanément comme ça au jour le jour
mais 05 vous plaît venez quel est
l'intérêt de vous présenter avec des
scores comme ça ou de matières vais
nommer mais nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir sortir la france et l'europe de
la crise actuelle nous sommes les seuls
nous sommes les seuls à respecter le
vote de cinquante cinq personnes deux
français qui ont voté non au traité
constitutionnel qui reprit elle était
très sale a revendiqué sa nouvelle salle
2004 tout le monde en convient c'est
il faut le savoir nous avons pressé vous
l'aimez
2004 faire des réunions partout et
lumière qui m'entourent et pour
expliquer aux citoyens
le dg comporter le tout est possible
qu'ils reprenaient en totalité le traité
de maastricht et toutes les directives
au second tour vous donner des consignes
de vote
non nous appartient tous les citoyens il
est individuel le ventre les gens
ouvrent nouveau dire ajouté je voterai
blanc à bien les coûteux
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ces mots que
même si on ne sait pas tout sur vos on
connaîtra peut-être un peu mieux merci
beaucoup